okay
okay i'm back
i'm back okay
for the love of god i'm gonna just
it's like okay so i spend my points
okay just don't show my penis please
i'm scared that it's gonna show my okay
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good
we're good
there's a streamer mode
please is there a streamer mode i need
that [ __ ]
[Music]
okay here we go yeah
okay thank god i have clothes on nice
that's me remove patch
i'm no longer part of the baker's
[ __ ] electric coupling module you
said it was nothing serious when i came
in
you said you were sure
welcome to cyberpunk 2077 first time in
the
in night city pay close attention to
tutorials learn more about the basic
mechanics of the game
or if you're already experienced edge
runner feel free to disable hints okay
i'll use the hints
uh-huh okay talk to the mechanic
[Applause]
i have clothes on all right streamer
mode
streamer mode where
where
aim assist cringe
is is sir streamer mode are you guys are
you guys lying to me
um
colorblind here we go no way
i read nude in my peripheral that's not
right
i just
yes
so they have that that's good i'll take
that
surely if they thought that much there
should be
no peepee mode or or what do you
no pp mode
where's the no paper mode
all right [ __ ] it
why he's hugging the border
it's got that motion blur
god damn
all right check engine step aside
step aside got simply
idea what to do
uh yeah a hot wire vibe has the coupling
to bring a hot wire
compressor run on and on could seize out
what do you mean gameplay sensor nudity
where
you guys are so [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
i have scroll down
don't waste my time ever again okay
let's see what happens
it's like i was telling you
not shabby at all questions how long
it'll last yet
that'll get me to night city i figure
something else out there
right
so doable it sure was satisfying that
not a solid fix might as well have used
spit and duct tape
it worked
antenna on this heap don't seem like it
packs a punch not liable to him
how long is the game roughly do you guys
know
okay i need to go back to main menu all
right gotcha i won't do it now then
if i can send some pp coming up i'll
just go back to menu
don't you swear to mine we're gonna hash
it out
yeah oh howdy cherry i know you owe the
sheriff a word
when you pay his town a visit to tell
him what's brought you here
maybe even over a cup of coffee just
passing through
i won't be staying long didn't answer my
question now
did you
name's andrew jones probably heard of me
nope you can't say that i have served in
spec
ops during the last war silver shoguns
bring any bells i can't say that it does
don't like to get along do you
whoa nomad vehicle might've expected
that
i'll just fix it and go i've no reason
to linger
no you sure [ __ ] don't
nothing boils my blood like a [ __ ]
stray
where'd your clan pitch camp
there is no clan there is no camp i'm
here alone
my family's in pieces that's why i'm
headed for night city
makes you an outcast where's keanu
reeves
sure as hell hope you'll be on your way
before long
i heard this place is famous for its
hospitality
glad to see it wasn't just rumors you're
damn right we
are when people come along who know how
to behave
i sold broadcasting comms tower on my
way in my antenna's down
and i need to radio someone what you
need is to hightail it out of here
without another word
ain't got no mind to see you drifting
around these parts
hey who matches their tie with their
shirt that's
so cringe i you like the sound of your
voice
don't you yeah
nothing oh i get to drive all right here
whoa all right here we go
hell yeah them so i'm supposed to go to
the telecom tower
can i exit the car no
i'm going that way i went i went wrong
way guys
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah all right turn around
turn around
[Applause]
what the [ __ ] was that
did you see that it's already glitching
i didn't do nothing wait you gotta bring
rules and [ __ ]
[Music]
it's lagging
hold up let me see if it's my end or
youtube it might be youtube
it is lagging a little bit is it the
motion blur
yeah i think it's the motion blur
because he shows up for me but not an
obs
that's weird
that is that better
it is kind of choppy how strange because
for me it looks great but in obs it
looks kind of [ __ ]
maybe if i set it on 60 fps which
obs is sat on right
uh what
oh my god what did i just do
oh it's because i haven't turned on
my
pp it's not motion blur
[Applause]
[Music]
then
is that better
okay wait i think i did it
that's that's better it's my obs
settings right
[Applause]
okay uh exit
we made it boys
kick it
damn damn son
it looks so good very pretty game
been a while since i played a first
person triple-a
turn on dlss why would i do all these
things do they really matter
come in raised you finally
willie mccoy it's good to hear your
voice
fee wish i could say the same
i need your help one last time
one last time again that's night city
it's kind of cool i like starting it
outside it
god damn you guys sure like to back seat
settings can i just play the game
uh all right where the [ __ ] is dlss then
all right increase the resolution a bit
then i can't see the chat i only have
one display
this is awkward hey look it's a little
bigger guys
i like higher field of view usually
film grain sfm
motion blur
it's on auto or should i put it on
balance
quality all right
we'll do low motion blur
and that's it now shut up let me play
right
place right time you were there
of course of course i was maybe the
client left a message
could you check for me
sure last time though i mean
client's name jackie wells
actually left a message he's waiting on
a farm
flicking you the globe data thanks willy
i owe you one
hey you do name is willie cringe
and don't call again
so do you start in the city if you use
the other ones
hey look i found
i found a
i can't pick it up hey
maybe we should use the ladder or maybe
we should just jump
i'm sorry i regret that but that was
cooler wasn't it
is food ready uh right now okay
okay right now oh god
uh i'm just gonna have a super quick
lunch
and we'll play for a long time today
okay so buckle up your seat belts
i'll bear back 10 minutes
[Music]
i guess thanks for waiting
head to the meeting place it's a good
thing i'm an excellent driver
[Applause]
probably one of the finest hopefully i
don't have to pay for
car repairs or some stupid [ __ ]
whoa
[Applause]
that's some off-road [ __ ] my man
let's go off road baby
i'm the best driver in the god damn it
oh my beautiful card
[Applause]
all right we're driving legally from now
on
only legal drive
hitting the spell [ __ ]
[Applause]
and we made it
what's up
is it still lagging i wonder why i don't
get it
that's mine oh i was worried i'd have to
turn to farming
yeah sure hope you're here for me
looks fine to me i believe i am are you
name's jackie wells v it seems you have
cargo that needs to be moved
oh where i'm from you share a bit about
your soul before you talk biz
huh it's kind of like a custom
okay it's good manners you know why
don't we start with you then
nc native right here got haywood in my
blood
i've never been to nc that doesn't mean
much to me
so imagine a place where everyone's like
your bro or sis
or a distant cousin at least i think i
understand
you don't have to like each other but
it's family that's haywood
that and everyone's packing iron
and you i guess one could say i'm from
my own haywood
you and me we're gonna get along fine
cargo let's load it in the car
i just like picking stuff on the ground
that's like my favorite part
this is mine this is mine this is mine
and this is mine sorry do you live here
you might not come
i got held up and you weren't exactly
easy to find
i decided to lay low you know the
sheriff
looked like one grouchy [ __ ] yep
can you repair my car please
trust me man i'm a great driver
i only drive illegal
look at this [ __ ]
[Music]
you have the manifest from the
transporter of course i do
but the fixture didn't give you the job
deets
[ __ ] i'm supposed to turn just making
sure
listen friend we're both professionals
ain't we
[Music]
hey [ __ ] sure you've both contraband
before
why are you nervous i like how he didn't
even react
he's driving backwards
[Music]
what the hell is that it's a boat
in the sky
[Music]
hey water crossing up my head what now
just act just like cool bro just act
cool
i'll do the talking all right let me let
me see why people complain about lag
[Music]
it is a bit choppy still i thought i
fixed it i'm so confused
it seems to be only when i'm driving
hmm
game can't handle driving
okay let's
try now
it's so kind of choppy isn't it
it's it's obs that does it i think
did i drive in the wrong no problem
no problem
sorry guys
let me just turn around
[Applause]
yeah it's super choppy what's going on
why [ __ ] why
it's not the bit right that would be the
internet
hmm
let's try this
how am i supposed to get there
please direct your vehicle to the
inspection area
[Music]
remain in your vehicle the security
check will begin
shortly it's super choppy on obs
something in the settings
are just like [ __ ] everything up
let's see if it's graphic settings
come on don't make me wonder that looks
better doesn't it
hand me the manifest grab these
let me see it's marked load
perfect what's that mean lost on arrival
it means the cargo is flagged as to be
lost as soon as you cross the border
so they know we're smuggling they're
about to find out
guess my graphics card can't handle obs
and the game that's
weird will report for further
questioning
driving will be the true test true
we want the customs officer to turn a
blind eye to our dubious docus
so far this has been a graphic setting
simulator bribe
oh yeah
forgot about that
right you forgot
i'll keep the engine running
do that it's gonna be a cock-up i know
it
if you're armed place your weapon here
might want to replace that buddy hello
hey hey
please sit down papers
is this routine it might be we'll see
hmm the character designs are very cool
what are you transporting
it's all in there
everything there's one additional
enclosure to the manor
nice ah yes remind me you drive for
which nomad clan
none no clan i drive for myself i'm just
chilling homie bold
and none too wise you know
whenever i see someone like you i'm oh
so grateful not to be on that side of
the table
the feeling's mutual go on now
your associate's waiting for you in the
car
thanks man don't forget to take your
personal items
in space don't wait a microsecond longer
send space to 7299 right now
oh my god
i'm doing it in the dead
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this
just adds my favorite channel
can't wait for the future burrito xxl
hell yeah it's big
where there is smoke there is smoking
creativity cancer
oh no don't smoke guys look how strong
you will get
hey hey is there a peepee thing coming
up
hi
the smell of kit oh
oh oh
[Music]
upgrade don't be soft
don't do anything to scratch every
whoa [ __ ]
[ __ ] this
oh sorry be careful with that toy
and welcome tonight those little shits
imagine night city is some kind of
paradise
what can you do wait how long was i
out what the [ __ ] is dark where's my car
there it is
sorry i got a little lobster what
happened in there
you're just chilling homie we need to
get out of here
yeah okay well on the wrong side
you drive now no
then i turned off copyrighted music god
damn you guys
look oh i got to fold it thank you never
mind
anyway sorry about snapping
it's just kind of annoying you know when
they tell me what happened back there
okay uh a custom stick head got nitpicky
and that ain't normal not to that extent
smelling trouble around the bend drive
jackie just drive
you have beautiful ice you know
someone's coming our way
this does not look good
come on mate stop your vehicle
immediately oh no
is this the time where i shoot shoot
whoa
draw a weapon holster weapon
shoot are you seriously are you trolling
me at this point
mute detect disable copyright music
shut up i'm not reading chat anymore
i'm shooting them right in the [ __ ]
face
is it better tamed i'm saying
oh there it is nice all right headshots
doesn't kill them apparently
am i just supposed to keep shooting and
then the car explodes or some [ __ ]
there you go maybe i should just shoot
the driver
what are you saying
what do you say about my mom
it's oh [ __ ] nice
i shouldn't have jumped up from that
tower earlier guys
i did it and my health regenerates nice
it's like call of duty it all makes
sense
have you played minecraft on hardcore
mode this ain't nothing
i'm kiddo stop here we need to sort out
a few things before we go on
i like the translation
i almost tagged our asses not what you
call smuggling
chicago was supposed to go smooth
no problems that was no problem calm
down
sometimes these things happen yeah bro
so isn't bro
border security tipped off the
corporation that we have their cargo
what's the deal with these borderlines
flipping us a finger as they [ __ ]
please
with no consequence they [ __ ] please
he assumed we didn't have a clan back in
us
and he was right
so what now we've crossed the
my [ __ ] god now you pay me
and we go our separate ways
i ain't gonna lie i'm a bit light
i can't pay you now i have something for
you once i collect my scrap for this
corporate crap we're carrying
huh and you just figured i would sit by
patiently
actually i wasn't gonna pay you at all
no regrets disappear as soon as we
crossed over
but you're all right
i appreciate the honesty thank you thank
you thanks
so what's next
now we take a peek inside
oh yeah what's in there
open it
peeky it says arasaka on the crate
we are robbing some heavy hitters maybe
we'll make some heavy money
a real iguana isn't that the old part of
tokyo
right oh [ __ ] hell yeah it's a
iguana hey how you doing holmes
you think you can make some money on it
what the [ __ ] is that sure
i think it'll make us happy us yeah
partner
we'll go half season any decent fixer
will find a loaded gog interested in a
rare gem like this
but he can be our friend though i always
wanted a picture let's keep him
what's his name yeah
and many dude look at his toes they're
huge
for what you'll be doing in night city
manny's got huge toes
manny the man why do you ask because i
got this feeling you got a lot of time
and nothing to spend it on and then see
in a city that lets you get by with our
buddies
but don't you worry let me help you find
digs
you got to live somewhere it's important
to have people you can turn
many wake up family
maybe you'll find your own down in night
city do you think he died in my car
crashes
thanks much appreciate it hey come on
it's nothing
you got chemistry you and me why is his
toe so long dude
partner hey ah many
cuddly little [ __ ]
okay partner time to grab the lizard
skirt
of dreams oh i love this town
okay there might be people coming out on
the steps of an orphanage
close your eyes i have a feeling
close your eyes hundred kids arrivals
but only half these gods will survive a
year and that's if it's a good one
and why do these peeps come to and see
well to be
street samurai like morgan blackhead and
waylon
the greater the risk the bigger the vote
kids
or so they say but you can only be a
major league player for so long
the faster you live the faster you burn
out even if there's no tits
you're you're better off eyes closed
it's cool cool segments
of legends the graveyard
this is dope matters not where you're
from
matters not where you start what matters
here
walk in night city
the city of dreams
chick we're looking for somewhere in
this building
probably crawling with the pineapples
they're kidnapped here half a year
japan town speaking of which
got you a little something thanks bro
i'll take training shard
in case you need to uh brush up on your
dance moves
what for some target practice in vr
tutorial yeah why the hell not
[Music]
whoa
this course is designed to reinforce
your fundamental combat abilities
and hone your reflexes the skills you
gain here will help you survive even
excel on the battlefield
i will train you to be effective with
firearms to use stealth tactics to
advantage and to hack into enemy
networks
because app militants
militech can't encrypt for [ __ ] but they
clearly got drilling jar heads in their
blood
now where the [ __ ] are you station one
you maggot
move move move i did i'm here i'm ready
to bust ass through this fascist
playground
what let's blast through a tactical
target practice program
you know a little warm up okay
damn this is cool
yeah i didn't think you'd find that too
tough yeah what do you say we crank it
up a notch
sure
nailed it hundred percent not bad
thanks but it's more realistic standing
around and take cover
uh crash to take her can't shoot
now i shoot back
i probably should have killed him there
shouldn't i surprise i'm over here now
you took a hit use a re-animator to
patch yourself up i did not take a hit
that must be a glitch
inhaler head to the training area when
you're good to go
i'm good to go bro
huh look brought some tunes don't shoot
don't shoot you know what
don't shoot don't shoot don't shoot
can't see my [ __ ] cross here
bro what are you even shooting at
peak bro nice hey level two
stand on the platform and we'll move on
okay
packing's the next item on the menu nice
uh whole time to act oh hold it okay
i'm scanning it's a server guys i found
it and that's a
computer i think and that's
surveillance camera hackable objects are
highlight green
okay so we can hack it by pressing z
this training module i will teach you
how to work a little hack magic on the
screen to distract the guard
hacker man coming right up yeah
all right we're gonna ping him a classic
hack
uh it's kind of broad okay used to
strike enemies
navigate the list of available quick
hacks with
q and e and then i pull up or down
what oh there we go we can distract the
enemy
and then f to execute
breaching trash
style over substance consider yourself
and hang out quietly
all right i'm quiet i'm i'm quiet
i'm quiet i was quiet what did she mean
i was quiet work a little hack magic on
the screen
to attract the guard [ __ ]
all right
uh yeah this one
trash style over substance
yeah corporate trench now take him out
to rest dude
all right all yours uh grab him
and then i'll do a kill i don't like
them
never smart to leave behind any trace of
your handiwork uh-oh
especially the dead kind now pick up a
little snack
a little snack for later
all right and you go
nice
okay now try to take them down in one
slick move
uh okay nice
[Music]
nice
it became like uh many you think you're
ready to try hacking some gonks in real
time oh hell yeah
okay we can we can hack the camera
and then we can more advanced allow you
to use environment and we
advantage all right so while
in controlling camera you can still
quick hack other devices
so i can hack one device to another
device
that's so cool uh breach protocol
absolutely the code of matrix
what am i supposed to do here
to upload you must recreate this code
i did
oh i see
now what detonate the grenade
hold yeah i did it
okay and you get you get bombed too you
both get bombed
this someone set us up the bomb
oh they died okay
see just needed to shut your brain down
and follow orders
in true militech fashion not too shabby
militech's algorithms put you on a
decent run
got additional modules if you want to
hone any other skills
before you finish up delta out now but
remember
the street's not going to give you any
hints or second chances
except it's a video game and i will get
as many chances as i got them please
[ __ ] all right we got two more
so first let's shape up those stealth
skills i'm probably an expert
selfler in every game ever so this
should be easy
uh tag a target with your optical
cyberware
press middle mouse button
enemies that are unaware of your
presence will continue their routines
pay attention to their behavior pen and
use
or you learn to sneak around them okay
and enter training area i gotta walk and
[ __ ]
i gotta walk over here
if you hear that sound you know you're
dead
oh [ __ ] he saw me when it
oh [ __ ] find cover quick uh and he
forgot i was there
he forgot i was there now
the recorder of death oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you saw me stealthy v
you ever relive a ninja just like that
stealth 100 this is how it's done
how i can't do this
why did i heal all right i got this i
got this i gotta pay attention to their
patterns right
right it's it's all about pat it's all
it's all about patterns
really you just sneak way past him
hey don't look at me bro
all right what is his pattern
let's go for it
can we take him out
master stealth there i did it i did it
guys
i did it what okay
hell yeah now the same thing only with
the camera uh-huh
all right i use my scanner
and i tag it
and then i hack it
i'll start cameras that can uh canon
detective orange okay well friendly ones
have green beams
they don't register noise
why can't i hack him
sorry he can't see me he didn't see me
but here i am
heck master
oops whoops
um sightseeing uh yeah [ __ ]
shut up
all right all right all right got this
it's got to get there right just hug the
wall
you didn't see me
but here i am stealth master 64.
just stand on the platform to exit all
right
this is how i walk as well that's how
you stealth
all right advanced combat master 64
coming right up
you didn't see me be here i am close
quarter combat
take him down but careful looks tough
i don't think so [ __ ]
hey hey how we
enemies at much higher level than your
mark with that uh-huh defending them is
extremely difficult
okay okay that'll do yeah
now maybe we find someone closer to your
weight class
all right fast attack
you want some of this raw swedish
strength coming right up
what you got what you got what you got
huh
oh you're shaking i can tell little boy
boom
yeah what's good
yeah you like combos [ __ ] i hate your
ass [ __ ]
i bet you never seen this ass punching
hold to charge okay all right here comes
the swedish destroyer
huh blah
uh okay
all right from easy to normal this next
he's blocking that's impossible how did
he know that
who can block your attacks
yeah stay down [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm supposed to block now right coming
up now
ah can't hit me gave me
uh huh
uh okay
am i supposed to let him do it there you
go
still kick your ass [ __ ]
i'm supposed to block two strong attacks
there we go
[Music]
what am i supposed to do in that counter
uh right mount
spun to block just before getting hit
now this fool loses his footing every
time he swings
use that get in there and land a
counterweight
yeah you like that
that's cool double time to
dodge okay
see wanna see this full punch in air
next
don't let him land anything
[Music]
i did it
use all your techniques to okay you've
done well in mastering the way of the
food
looks like you're cruising already
are we done that was it good luck v
thanks
i have to walk out
[Music]
cringe so
not bad huh we're just shipping and
we're shopping
all right let's do this
elevator this way
where's my katana give me my katana
right click garage what do i
oh do i
oh i got a call hold up one targets
sandra dorset
targets biomon went mute a couple hours
back why are her eyes closed
target could have possibly flatlined
already not sure you're in time
we're in time bug we sure you're on
phones but
that don't make you any less part of
this squad squad
charming
bug could at least try to be nice
nudity hell no
can't save right now oh okay
close your eyes kids just look at the
floor
well just looking at the floor i'm not
looking at anything hey
uh we're going to a nightclub aren't we
oh geez
what does that mean titties targets
should be inside but i got zero eyes on
her bioma
fingers crossed it's not too late oh i
hate this life or death
[ __ ] hurry get the [ __ ] out [ __ ]
give me that try hacking the door i
think you can trip it on your own v
oh yeah i can i i know how to hack you
hold down
and you execute
all right we'll have we have to kill the
nude ones
no nudity i gotta kill them really fast
she
is naked naked
i can't tell
no that's a woman can't go near it
okay let's go back to main menu
and turn on streamer mode everyone says
it's in main menu
[Music]
thank you
great to have you back so then did you
all hear about that arasaka aircraft
carrier docked in night city
called kujira or the whale
yo look at the graphics on those noodles
man that's sick
man all right now we can look at the
lady
no senping mode yeah yeah
she's covered up oh yeah sandra dorset's
protected under echelon 2 corporal
immunity
our girls top shelf this is
there's making sure she doesn't come up
all right just playing it safe here
[Music]
i am
it's [ __ ] hacking time bro
got the matrix over here 55
yeah success
distract them
consider yourself act
[Music]
off pick the prick up
you didn't see me
bro you don't have to whisper they can't
hear it's super loud dude
[Music]
i didn't do anything i swear i swear
is that it
he [ __ ] needed me don't do that
bro i'm head shotting left and right
trust me
how do i execute it uh okay
he's running coward
jesus relax bro
i'm almost dead
oh [ __ ] i thought it was undercover my
bad
uh sir that something happened here i
don't know what
[Music]
uh
that that is not that does not count
that is not again no thank you
oh we're back here cool that's what i
wanted
sir that's uh i think the game is
glitchy it's a new game
you're welcome
on your toes all right i'm hacking bro
i'm hacking bro
i did it guys
okay so don't die
[Music]
bro we don't have to be quiet it's
really loud
[Music]
how do i
reboot optic oh what is this distract
yeah
all right so who's there no one no one
no one no one
i thought he was distracted
i saw the end he's
perfect name
perfect aim 100 aim
how is he not dead my [ __ ] teammate
does nothing
no way not neither
all right we got this easy is he a
oh what the [ __ ]
perfect aim perfect aim
ah that's a nade
stop don't shoot swedish
can i get a better weapon please
thank you
just die
thank you yo check my health bro
nice that was clean
[ __ ] where the hell is our target look
around gotta be there somewhere
i'm just loading bruh oh
can i not use that
noise oh hell yeah please tell me
yes it's mine it's mine now
oh the future is beautiful look at this
gaming setup
i'd open my inventory hell yeah
oh [ __ ] i had a shotgun
can i pick attachment do i have any mods
that's it are these pistols better
60 the one i have it does six they
gotcha
and then this i don't have anything i
suppose
okay cool
no but i want the big boy gun
shotgun is pretty cool but
i want this i like this
jesus [ __ ] christ at least he's not
naked
what the [ __ ] i think i got her got her
target
we make it she alive about to find out
the jack into our biomod need to know
what we're dealing
that's a weird thing to say in front of
a okay
[Music]
sandra dorsett nc five seven zero four
four two
dramatine platinum platinum [ __ ]
let's not look at her probably should
have swooped in if she sneezed you never
know they brought my sleeve to the
transmitter
looking at a hat
[Music]
got an idea check her neural board find
a shard
yeah pull it that'll be what's muting
the biomass
nipples are dangerous guys removing now
i always said it
sandra if you are conscious assume
recovery position
now an emergency evacuation unit has
been dispatched and is due to arrive at
your location
in 180 seconds no month claims trauma
will be here in three minutes
your premium plan will cover 90 of the
projected costs of your rescue and
treatment
let's get her off that ice
all right pick her up
ah [ __ ] he's flatlining
jackie air hypo [ __ ] this is bad hey
[Music]
what the [ __ ] how are we doing i think
holy [ __ ] it worked
get her outside
[Music]
this is the worst mission of all time
get this thing off me quick
what the why is there so much profanity
degenerate future society
all right you can have it
[Music]
okay that's fine
tt133 to control patient nc570442 secure
stimulus being administered 70
milligrams dopamine
110 norepinephrine 800 for energy
[Music]
the art direction is so dope
like look at this [ __ ] chair dude
that's a nice chair what up let's get
out of here
elevator gets us to the garage direct
hey bro bro bro
bro bro bro cutting my wires now
oh you didn't mean dirty
listen i got this thing i'm bringing
home a snack is that all right
hmm i got a date with misty but
i can't take the metro how's it gonna
look for me
only be hanging jack but don't get used
to yo they got [ __ ] burgers and fries
and [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
the future is here thank you
all right but i drive you home man
that's all right she's all yours
i'm beat as it is
a little nibble in case i get peckish
excuse me the job's done
[Music]
how did it go our client is alive and
well
of course she's alive and well that's
what we agreed isn't it
splendid your payment awaits you great
ready to come and grab whenever you lie
given right away
but i guess home is the only place you
wish to be now
the ncpd has surrounded watson
the district is closed if you ought to
make it past the corridor you must move
fast
thanks for the heads up swing by to see
you later
words out the ncpd is going to put
watson on lockdown
i'm going to sleep in my own bed tonight
we better put it in fifth
leave i'll be sleeping with this tonight
if you know what i mean
a little body pillow
all right
no where did he go no
oh come back he's outside
he's still breathing he's still moving
oh
oh no oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry
not just any other city morgan blackhand
adam smasher legends are born
dude i had a snack right there jackie
they're locking down watson converted
my [ __ ]
[Music]
all right i got the shotgun for some
reason [ __ ] drive jackie
it's really the shotgun the best option
here
keep her steady
maybe
okay
the [ __ ]
scratched your baby up pretty bad that's
all right
it's okay it can wait let's just focus
on getting home
bro i gotta pee
maybe they fix that in the future
that'll be sick i don't have to pee
anymore
pulling out all the stops
what does the lock down to further
nervous necessary
why does it say new york city police
department sir ma'am
damn are we ever lucky we ran into you
really what's it that makes me so
special
a heart of gold cause only somebody with
a heart of gold can understand just how
much i need to get back to my girl
you're a girl uh-huh
i'm gonna be worried sick if i don't
show i mean
i'm trying to be a stand-up guy she's
giving me a chance
waiting hmm that's a look at him
no model citizen maybe but he's a good
kid
they got [ __ ] mechas and [ __ ] that's
sick let them through
but they don't last thanks bro
on your way you have a good evening now
officer
ma'am
you ass kisser you're a little smoochy
ruchi
you've done that too many times so you
can be nice when you feel like it
what am i not nice oh night city gotcha
i'm always i thought that was a nickname
little china
all right more people will shoot i guess
i don't look like your average boy what
the [ __ ] in this city
all right while this plays out i'm just
gonna pee and you tell me what happened
when things fly out of hand dogs out
there though
just
well she was over poor bastards
but they had it coming
[Music]
made it almost at your place what about
you
not likely to make it back to haywood
now till v
don't let me through sure about that
oh yeah i'll play nice jackie again
[Applause]
sweet dreams then
all right what'd i miss elon musk
appeared
what tell misty i said hi i will
hey luego
can you stop that
[Music]
yo level up all right uh reflexes
mantis blades update ooh
eagle eye origins
[Music]
yeah give me that how many more do i
have
handguns i can or blades we gotta do
blades right strong attacks with blade
steel
it's insufficient
we'll go blade build a ship shop build
as i've always called it
oh not this [ __ ] again
[Music]
do i have to press the elevator or
something
i was here good evening
my first guest tonight is the president
of the church
i forgot
our father in heaven and our
second guest is karina lee host of the
chip and
program which promotes the use of
cybernetic implants
i'm not treating you beautiful can't
complain ziggy
thanks for having me now i'd like us to
talk about the most exclusive
and highly sought after implant on the
market today
arasaka corpse relic but
maybe we ought to make sure our fair
audience is up to speed
karina what is relic exactly in a word
if you could in one word i'd say
immortality immortality
really that's right relic
allows you to transfer the consciousness
please
don't do this
i have kids
oh stupid gates busted again third time
paid to get it fixed the last two got to
be some kind of scam
i'm gonna have a word with this super oh
yeah
don't do this
this
how long have i been muted
what the [ __ ]
this is what i normally do before i go
to bed
what the [ __ ] is happening stop this
that's kind of cool
maybe the future isn't so bad after all
i'll shower with my clothes on
why did no one tell me i was looking at
the chat
act one
[Music]
time you got up i think i might have
caught something
when i jagged into that corpus bio mine
no neurovirus sir
need to see vic let him tell me what's
got my head reeling my stomach churning
okay let me take you i brought you a
ride
throw on some threads make me downstairs
ooh buy two tickets get third from free
heart heart heart heart
buy yours now heart heart heart heart
scam alert
penis nano gel scam alert i don't care
i want the penis nana gel no matter
what it's my penis nano gel
and i got a damn money
these haters
did i just buy stuff am i poor now what
did i just do
oh no
shorts man you gotta wear shorts
these are garbage dude oh god i bought a
bunch of crap
take it off take it up
this game is so over the top it's almost
uh get out of get out get out
get the [ __ ] out get the [ __ ] out it's
happened
it's happened hey v regina jones here
get the [ __ ] out give
get back here get back here
get back here
it's happened they won
they won it's happened it's happened
they won oh he had vodka on him
can they not die oh they can die okay
[ __ ] i gotta get i gotta bounce bros
[ __ ] the cops
sorry guys it wasn't me i swear
i didn't do nothing i didn't do nothing
guys don't write me out
that's right i'll just jump from here
i know i know what i'm doing don't worry
about
you do like this you land on the edge
and then
you
what did i do i don't get it what
happened
that was a set i was i was set up for
that i don't get it
it was not my fault that does not count
i said that
i i was barefoot that's why they shot me
because i was barefoot
yeah we got some milk vic let him tell
me what's got my head reeling my stomach
churning
all right don't kill random people
gotcha i brought you a ride
oh they got the burrito hell yeah
i don't understand so i have to walk
here right and then it tells me it's
over there
and then it tells me to go there what
the [ __ ] does that mean
okay cool
why does he do they
the [ __ ] oh my god
oh the mini map
honey you gotta tell me how you got to
beat you
uh just started youtube channel i was in
sweden
i was selling hot dogs and people
started watching my scary amnesia let's
plays
and then oh you're leaving okay
then don't ask
curious to see how he handles the likes
of me
so how about it he's too tall to be
taller one
let's do this light on your feet keep
that head moving
all right you got this
[ __ ] stay down you got one hell of a
punch there
monetizing it yeah i'm a youtuber i'll
monetize anything
what have you got for sale only top
shelf
give me a sword i just want a blade a
bat
machete give me that
is that mine now how do i buy it
yeah buy it it says sell it
did i just buy it and sell it again
hold it hold that
oh i got it oh [ __ ] you
okay
cool
you mentioned something about fighting
hmm
i've seen you landing blows in the ring
you've got sharp
instinct good edge you can go far
especially if you get chipped these
fights
let's just say they aren't clean but
very loot lucius ran trusted you were
made
both of them nice i get a small
percentage of the total winnings you
know as
you're at i don't need shoots trust me
you get the rest
oh i get it you want to get rich off my
blood sweat and tears
hey you got to make a buck somehow right
at least i'm giving it to you straight
fights happen in different parts of the
city you choose where you want to go
put down your eddies and start swinging
oh i'm going to swing bro
manage to drop every last one of them
you get a chance to fight the grand
finale
that all clear sure crystal that sounds
fun good
oh except you won't be setting foot
outside or once
not yet start
i believe in you me time to show this
city
what you're made of
so how are you how are you doing
i was joking i want to leave about those
fights you mentioned vvv
if you don't have a titanium fight
that's cool featuring
let's check out the wait i can just walk
away
let's check out these gyms how's you
want me to spot you bro
yes lift it now [ __ ]
yeah let's go
oh oh oh
strunk he's strong as hell
holy [ __ ] oh my god those curls
[ __ ] howdy do it
let's go king let's go champ oh
[ __ ]
excuse me i want to do like uh that's
not a leg machine
let's pump some iron bros
all right bro come on push it
there we go
bro i'm spotting you bro relax you done
with this machine bro
you done with the machine bro
it's my turn on the machine bro you've
been hugging this [ __ ] for 20 minutes
i see you
all right let's go to the kabuki fight
regina jones here if you're looking for
work in watson
give me a call how'd you find me how'd
you even know my name
i know where to gather my intel could
even call me a collector
later me virtue
and theatrical performances in the no
tradition the sponsor for the festival
is the arasaka corporation
and in an exciting day all right i guess
we're gonna
fight some baddies
put on some are those crocs she has to
die
sorry let me just
it's fine
it wasn't me
they'll never find me
how do they keep finding me
it wasn't me
hey man can i start the quest man of the
hour
yep
all right sorry
[Laughter]
okay let's go back
oh what the [ __ ] let's check them
let's check them oh you're good my dude
you're good
man of the hour she's took you long
enough
worked up an appetite just waiting
sit down let me finish this
something about a surprise yesterday am
i remembering right or
just had a brain fart probably both
because
you usually forget [ __ ] but it just so
happens
i think i might have bagged this as
sweet ass j.o.b
what does that mean maybe it's not as
big as that but
just that he's fronted by a little known
someone named dexter deshawn
only the top fixer in night [ __ ] city
fat ass black jesus of the afterlife
300 pounds of partly gold-plated
cool so what's the gig
we meant to come out in one piece our
lord and savior wants to tell you
everything himself
face to face oh no pressure but uh
his
all right let's see what old deck says
brain dance i want to do that
dex is a real deal when it comes to
fixers don't get me wrong
don't got nothing against the padre or
macaco but
i'm saying don't get me started on
fixtures
they catch a client find the cheapest
gong to do the job
then drop their corpse at a landfill
[ __ ]
hit the nail on the head
brought your wheels give them to my guy
yesterday to smooth over the dents after
our uh
dust up with scabs thanks jake much
appreciate it
you can call your active vehicle for
your current location with the
oh top notch work some teslas
oh it's lagging oh oh
we'll see about that are we rolling or
what
let's go let's feel this factory new
ride
dope
first stop ripper duck and holmes
easy on the gas huh i just ate
i was supposed to stop by viggs anyhow
excuse me
don't say she's so sweet
really gets me you know excuse me
excuse me
what the [ __ ] just happened i just drive
a car
i just drive car
[Music]
oh my camera for us hold up
hold up gamers
all right i'm a legal
i just citizen
i was supposed to stop by vixx anyhow i
got a date
you don't say she's so sweet
really gets me you know
this is smooth
[Music]
dr vector will see you now
all right i'll sit tight over here
me and misty got a little catching up to
do
you look pleased because i am about the
good old days
we got a new job lined up from a big
hitter at the afterlife
oh is it gonna be dangerous
don't you worry i'm supposed to go in
i can pet the cat ew what the [ __ ]
it's very detailed and the art direction
is
insane insane
what the [ __ ] are you doing today drop
the gun
drop the gun i can't shoot children
are you serious he has a gun he can
defend himself
ah this is [ __ ] can i shoot the cat
my mother waits for me
yeah yeah that's what i thought that's
what i thought
all right
vicky surprise every old ripper it's
good to see it
good to see you too it's been a while
what do i owe the pleasure today last
gig
had to jack into a client's neuro socket
i think i might have gotten spiked
experiencing migraines nausea
hypersensitivity to bright lights
cute cats caboodle all right kid
we'll sort you out in a flash besides
that
how are things uh looking for another
new kit
but tools not toys time i built up my
sights and got a grip
really now finally yep
vic shit's getting real got a job from
dex to sean
hitting the major leagues any tag that
can perform
the dexter design well
that is something but toe gang
hasn't paid you yet
quit crying vic i'll bring you the
eddies later with interest
you know i will hmm
last time you're here
chair please sit down relax i am
karoshi optics best i've got and should
be about right under the circumstances
hey i got new eyes sweet
i'll jack it you peruse and chews while
i scan
see what's going on inside
uh cybernetics implants are mechanical
replacement for the organic part of the
body they can even you superhuman-like
abilities but you can improve your
comfort because we didn't have easter
eye and hazardous conditions
although complex in 2017 the
installation of cyberware is still
an invasive and sometimes dangerous
medical procedure only specialists known
as ripper docs
are trusted to install the cyberware
safely
okay what do we want a skeleton
i want a bone i want new bones man
titanium bones [ __ ]
all right well
i want legs i always wanted legs
reinforce my ankles what the [ __ ] is the
point then
all right give me a new uh
frontal cortex i wanna
fine i'll have a new eye then
enhance i'll get a new hand
mark one like i said decent enough
scanner
displays data on your cornea cherry on
the tops of built-in external we'll get
legs eventually guys don't worry
in layman's terms any surveillance cam
will capture your face as a blur
i just remember your body will still
show up as crystal clear
hmm this should do the trick
talks to karoshi tech too
i'm ready carve away excellent
let's do this
lay that major league arm of yours right
here
just like that thanks
now a bit of anesthetic yeah okay
feel anything
play by play though really doc
can you get an ass in plane dentist
always going on
and on don't be mean now remember i'm
old i got a shaky gannic hand
could slip lights out for a minute all
right
uh sure yeah
okay let's test this see the magic
what's happening
linking you in
you might feel a little discomfort at
first word vision
low contrast glitches
well how's it look feel all right to you
uh yeah oh this is fantastic vic
oh beautiful
all right so scanning people optical
cyborg can probably give with a lot of
useful information such as strong
how strong an enemy might be who is in
their crew and what type of weapon they
use as a skill netrunner you can use a
list of quick hacks which
you can use against enemies time for the
scanner
it might take you a few seconds to
adjust resistant to fire sometimes
rarely the charm
with anything really best ripper docking
once again
i also injected an ncpd file search
from antennae nerdy wells you know
exactly what they never did well
it ought to work like a charm now draw
your weapon
you should see your ammo count in a
brand new site
victor not bad i don't know what to say
kiss him
say you'll take this and remember the
dosage two whiffs now
and another two in an hour i'm gonna
forget it
bro remem remind me thanks again vick
you're the best
i owe you
go on kid show them what you're made of
and once you hit the big leagues don't
forget where you came from
okey dokey is the child still here
where the child go i'm not going to hurt
him of course
just want to talk then
i can release it for you but you'd have
to watch out for negative energy fields
v yo listen up this [ __ ] is annoying me
he's waiting in his ride for you
ain't gonna hop to where he's parked
next to gramsci burgers
okay do my best to talk us up
we scan him now he's weak to electricity
he's wanted
what does this [ __ ] say ah
[Music]
listen i've got this delicate matter
that's why i called you
the number of cyber psycho attacks in
the city is on the rise
now that's probably not news to you but
this issue matters to me
for a few reasons there are people who
say cyberpsychosis can be treated all
around us
but i believe even an unproven therapy
is still better than a bullet to the
brain
if i get a tip about a possible attack
i'll give you a call
maybe you can investigate before max
tack hits
but remember you're not there to execute
anybody
try to incapacitate the attacker and
i'll send someone to pick them up
i hope that's all clear gotcha fam
i'm just ordering some snacks i'm really
hungry
salted caramel
yeah i don't care about that cameras are
all around us even within us your joys
your worries your life and it's by dog's
spectacle
do you truly believe that those who have
sold you your mechanical eyes have
resisted the temptation
cameras are all around us even within us
your joy your world for life who the
hell is this
all mere spectacle let's just say you're
right
so what should i just gouge out my
optics
thanks but no thanks you are beyond
salvation
but not the children of the future life
untainted by
surgery of the sacrilege
we can yet save them may the mother she
gary the prophet
is he wearing a trash bag he's wearing
the latest alex collection
but who are those nice followers
why the titans of entertainment in alpha
centauri
in their wretchedness they placate their
weary and oppressed masses
by putting our laughter out tears on
full display
i'll get in on this open your mind
before it is too late
nice this game is [ __ ] awesome dude
like this is max nova i just can't
oh all right let's look at the
what's happening here this is a strip
club
okay can i come in pretty please
can i come in all right
they are coming how do i unholster
my weapon forgot which bun
that's heal i
i hit it again just for good luck
where's my car ah just as i parked
it of course
all right
let's not run anyone over
you double tap alt i got it
glad i took the ride there
all right
yo mr v a pleasure what's up big d
in the flesh ample indeed
of urine i like the retro look of this
car times in a blaze of glory smelling
near like posies without seeing your
30th
this some sort of test just a pet topic
of mine
you mean riddles no mr v
ontology
all right listen close scanning a
serious job now
playing gargantuan compared to smashing
up a scav
let me hear it what's the job there's
this
prototype check a biochip to be precise
jobs to grab it simple
yeah guessing it belongs to a court
arisaka surely that's no problem
everyone's saying it's ksi it's a black
guy it's ksi
get it he's fine [ __ ]
you ain't playing around got a feeling
this could be a start of a beautiful
friendship
i it on my shoes
you got a plan two things first
a conundrum with the maelstrom the
design in this game is
so [ __ ] cool second to rendezvous
simple client who brought us the job all
the details
she wants to parlay with one of the team
what's the issue needs resolving with
maelstrom got a beef
it's not a shot
i got a classic tail for you protein
hell yeah
inject me bro got away with the gear
corp don't even know
maelstrom's involved now see
convoy was carrying the flathead a
little combat bot a prototype
and i need me that bit of high grade
military because if we don't get that
body
we don't get no soccer chip and we
should i
i want that iguana back but don't get it
or money back
it's a single use toy now i flat out
purchase the damn thing from maelstrom
problem is i did so from it markiplier
gained some weight
haha i say wins because brick was the
leader
three days after we'd see the idea his
friend and gang mate won
simon randle aka royce plane dropped his
ass
royce is in charge now and i got no way
of knowing if he aims to honor his
predecessor's work
to add to this shitstream one meredith
style of militech has developed an
interest in
[Music]
if her life depended on finding it the
one lead she's got
zip tied in her trunk stick up this game
is insane
it's blowing my mind dude be wise to
think how you could use that
of course to do so you'll need that
frazzled cat's info
sending it now
isn't it isn't it dope client
what's her thing why she need to meet
woman's name's evelyn parker bedner
wasn't easy
put the word out i was looking for any
kind of intel
right and some brothers from pacifica
got back to me
told me to stop looking in the convo
anyway our little client insisted on
meeting someone with skin in the game
you know who'll be there for it all
am i back
obs crashed on me
what what
the hell
oh okay i think i got
everything time i got to work well
that's just music to my ears
i'll set up the meet with miss parker at
lizzie's bar flat head though is gonna
be
all you this is why you should use a
bandicam
just looking out i'm just like blown
away by the details
now there's ksi now we found him
the [ __ ] i know they have some
celebrities in the game
i understand the situation and i take
full responsibility
one more thing mr b
quite life or blaze of glory
later now i can forgive it being quite
glitchy i don't really care
it doesn't take me out of the game
all night every night street cred
performing certain action with the world
of street cred billy or striker to make
a name for yourself in the night city
underworld doing some will open new
opportunities
jagster talk to dex
clem to want to check our pro cred but
to me it feels more like he tangled us
up with me
bro this is combat bot
military prototype maelstrom clapped it
then decks paid to take it off their
hands just before the gang goons had to
switch up and manage
we haven't even met keanu reeves yet
i haven't i've never played a game like
this dex once is talking to roy
it's blowing my mind it's of some
militech agent too but
i don't know how much help she stands to
be
how do you enter photo mode
p is the character okay can i level up
my character by the way
yeah i have some points available
intelligence
it's quicker hacking i think i want to
go with the blade stuff right
i have to unlock this first right
nice i have two attribute points what's
the
difference
oh i see
then there's the other thing gotta meet
the client who put the job on the tape
so this is photo mode what the [ __ ] is
this
i don't want to be in the shot
[Laughter]
oh i see cool
what
i can add a sticker nice
did i take it
this is cool evelyn parker
you oh what's dex gonna do right around
in his limo jet chicks up on the hollow
parker wants to meet someone on the crew
dex gave me the nod
they must know what he's doing so how
you want to play this
this is super far away why don't you
drop me here
bell strummer parker was first
i say we knock on maelstrom's door first
pound actually
in that case oh man you're a man of
culture i see
another day another dollar
[Music]
so that's me in the future eh
was i not doing another quest whoa what
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] barefooted
we can be five oh where'd he go
let's check out crafting
can't craft my blades
insufficient components
my three is two
then i have a quest here i'm so confused
i can grab a buy net running equipment
so i can change to track jobs well since
we're here why don't we do this
on the edgenet
sick for a pickup quarter
48. that's mine
is that the tambourine guy
[ __ ]
hotel pooh that's where i want to go
how do i get up
here we go
it's like uh future japan but everyone
isn't degenerate
yeah broseph brewing company
be your best self
okay
ted bug sent me said you'd have
something for me
you're v right she had me hold the demon
for you okay it should work on any third
gen deck
okay glad to grab a demon always
you could test it now i have an access
point
if you'd like that is you might extract
some shim soft or
sub routines seems worth a try either
way
uh quick hack component how much money
do i have 200
this costs nothing i also grab that one
can i play this
watch it
oh hell yeah you're again
oh what a [ __ ] pose
[Laughter]
what's going on brother
i ain't going down there
i almost fell
i've fallen i thought i hit m
uh so what's the main quest is this one
right
i'm not gonna walk
there it is is that my car
oh [ __ ] you that's so cool
hey
oh yeah
[ __ ]
ah there you are hello
it's me
nice bike let me hear what you squared
away
so dex already paid the maelstrom is for
the corporal bot
thing is can't be sure the gang goons
are still willing to hand it over
he paid up front
well whatever let's go get this tech
you scheme yet you got a plan
that [ __ ] can go smoothly it's checking
on my food this is maelstrom
gang world ain't too complicated mites
right
the strong survive either you [ __ ]
others
or you get [ __ ] that's life so
into the board beast then
let's go see these bastards all right
let's knock on their door see if they
even open up
call a militech aiden meredith style
optional
how do i call her
she's a gang like any other right here
start by telling me how you got this
let's meet cut a deal a deal
fine first exit off skyline driving
towards the nid
storm channel under the overpass meet
you there
i'm not going to do that
i'm going with homes
oh so if i hold down alt it gives me
this menu
go on let them know we're here
[Music]
i did it
so where am i right now
so confused this is where i am right now
we're tracking this job
sorry i'm a gamer welcome gotta get this
done
uh where the [ __ ] is inner come
there that's what i wanted to do
all right
just loading sharing is carrying right
cozy i can override it i could use a few
plants though
oh yeah they look damn well prepared
don't think i've ever seen security like
this in the chow factory
gear from the jack convoy gotta be
must have been all over it like maggots
on dead meat
you hear about their boss royce dex
mention them
call them special
anti-personnel mine directional shrapnel
spitter
my favorite subtle
everything to look at just makes it
interesting that's why
even if it's if the game starts off kind
of slow i i still enjoy myself
barefoot gang get in the elevator
stay cool they're just trying to spook
us
i'm just looting i'm just here for the
for the goods
we're on man turf so what do you want
you got a bot model mt-0d12
called the flathead and
the hell you care guy i represent
already paid brick for it i'm just here
for the pickup i can talk direct to
royce if necessary
nah you talk to me name's tong tong
dum dum
i don't i didn't bring a couch did you
bring a couch
oh he's got one good
we're just chilling
yeah me too [ __ ] ass on the [ __ ]
couch poop on the couch open the couch i
thought you'd never
ask say you're as dead
sit down this ain't gonna end well
but [ __ ] chad [ __ ]
all right
it's cool it's got that japanese style
bun i didn't realize
thanks i'm good
say no to drugs kids it's that easy
whatever you say straight princess
you think you went a little haywire on
there here we go
need to see it suit yourself
[ __ ] tricked out this thing dynamic
thermal optic
oh hell yes the robot dog
prototype actuators made of titanium
vanadium
kevlar composites weak to
crawling up electricity dangling from
ceilings he's worth 10 bucks
you could lose your lunch
what you think
i'll have to do
it's all paid up oh no
i don't see any [ __ ] brick around
here do you oh what happened to your
face
bro
come on can't expect me to pay for this
thing twice
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
it can't be
you'll pay twice because i say you'll
pay twice
[Music]
all right you want the flathead i better
see some eddies you already got the
edits for it
you want to offer us a discount big one
a discount [ __ ]
you know you never did say who sent you
never did say who you're working for
[Music]
let's take him out [ __ ] large don't
laugh at me lars
all right give me give me the blame
hold up hold up hold up hold that
i [ __ ] slice the [ __ ] out of them
[Music]
haha your nose bro
what is happening
[Music]
why won't you die dude
there we go it's got stabbed
nice oh look at all the loot
ah they were rich
oh hell yeah
don't kill him you tell me now
you tell me [ __ ] now
oh god what have i done do i have boots
yet
no
oh look at that i got i got his little
finger
[Music]
we got new pants [ __ ]
level required
all right we've got the set bot and
controller
oh now i level up for [ __ ] sake
strong attack see 30 more
all right
do i have a flashlight because this game
is [ __ ] dark
maybe i should use machine gun on this
mission
it's so dark
future of me
bro i can't see where i'm going
it says i'm supposed to go
up gotcha
oh good it's moving let's go
i'll just jump
am i supposed to jump down here
ah they almost spotted me [ __ ] all that
should be in gameplay right
can i increase brightness
[Music]
[ __ ] all right let's look at our hacking
abilities
nice
so
such a strange way to hacking
oh they're they're distracted the [ __ ]
out right now
uh that could have gone better
i'm not hitting him
how's my friend doing
he's not dead
what is that
[ __ ]
am i i'm out of ammo
[Music]
where'd he go
where is he
what is hurting me am i on fire
four damage let's go
this weapon sucks
am i overheating
i need the other weapon i have no ammo
nice
how do i keep overheating
is he dead no
one more
someone's hacking me and that's making
me overheat
what
how do i thought i could go through
there
where is he
[Music]
who's ready to party
got him [ __ ] they have so much help
for you 69 epic number
all right do i have ammo now yes
nice
i guess i just got to keep looting
let's go
go
[ __ ] i'm about to die
whoa what the [ __ ] is happening the
screen is insane what a joke
this game feels like the meme where like
they show you too much in the game
i can only have the shotgun
trying some ammo would be nice
where the [ __ ] is he
oh my health i went down
damn [ __ ]
[Music]
for bloody stupid in it
hold up my snack is here
oh i just saw that right
are they at the door
it did not look like they oh my god
hey
all oh
these are so good but they're so tiny
148 100 150 calories
i can have two
oh man
you gotta get those leg games bro
just a minute
jackie well you know who you're messing
with
oh
the overheating is so [ __ ] annoying
trying to conserve ammo
didn't work
[Music]
sorry bro
shotgun is pretty good here
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
stay down what
i'm dying and dying
[Music]
where is he
oh okay
nice
oh we got boots finally
should i put on the boots yeah
more armor
anything special
so how do i use grenades is it g like
all the games
rebooting his optics
boot gang
so you can't just sell through all this
might be easier
you didn't see me but here watch this
i'll do it like this
stab the [ __ ] out of them
it's stabby time
go go
come here come here
god damn stop overheating me
[Music]
ah [ __ ] is crazy come here
i'm dead now [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] i died so quick
i thought it was only one girl upstairs
and the guy climbed up
all right we're back to stabbing then
[ __ ] this is difficult
all right let's turn up the [ __ ]
cameras
watch watch me stealth through all of
this
you didn't see me
easy all right we're gonna have to take
them out
stay still
it works every time
oh i'm coming for you baby
nice hello there
all right let's get this [ __ ] on top
oh they jumped down
[Music]
stop jumping up and down super annoying
what is happening sorry
price
easy
we're not all bad you know let's talk
okay
feeling alone tonight feeling alone and
kinky women men or a gen eight gender or
fluid
we got someone for you and we're as
naughty as we are sexy we're just one
easy other way for learning at your
dirty advantage check out a
double trouble with genitals
an amelia taylor scale on board
what are you waiting for
double trouble
turn the [ __ ] off
i i'm barefooted again
surprise
i was just joking anyway
maybe i should shoot
oh my god he's not dead
all right is there one more
[Music]
it's stab time
nice
do i have better weapons
yeah pretty much everything nice
[Music]
even the handgun is better
nice is she not dead
[Music]
it's chopped knees [ __ ] how do
you speak it
ship shop ship shot right remember
[Music]
crafting specs
oh oh oh
they're so distracted they don't even
know what's going on
we can still take out one
what's going on turn
[ __ ]
no i try to take him out
oh my god this gun is so much better
you think with all this cyber optics
[ __ ] i would actually see in the dark
all right it's japanese time
finish him off nice
that was awesome yeah
gotta loot everything
brain feel i gotta
[Music]
sweet dude [ __ ]
nice
grenades our middle mouse bun thanks for
telling me now
[Laughter]
no begging no debt no corporal strings
attached
and the flathead's ours that's the way
to do busby
couldn't agree more tough to argue yeah
cause i'm right always nice of you to
notice
ah i love this town the city of endless
there was a katana in my storage are you
serious
i think i'm doing a katana build on this
playthrough you can do damn near
anything can i get a bike too straight
or not
even then you go out with a bang right
and the street will talk
street will remember it's a win-win
what now jack what now
now i go back find misty do something to
make me feel alive
again it could have shot us up good back
there
but no two ways about it risks come with
the job jack
ducked in time to avoid death's sweeping
sight again
because i can upgrade blades right
strong attacks
deals 50 yeah now we can get reduced
stamina because of all attacks with
blades
increased attack speed
[Music]
oh yeah give me that
nice
nice only right to celebrate even though
we get to do that lunch
don't forget to let dex know we got his
toy for him
samurai build i went into the pole
dumbass
[Music]
all right can't save right now
sure of course there was trouble royce
couldn't have given two shits you and
brick had shaking on
still you use the barefoot woman
did it without militech holding my hand
didn't want to risk it
so how'd you get that cat royce to hand
over the flat head
only way i know that always works brute
force
you got some balls mr b what about the
meet with evelyn parker
still on the to-do list that meets the
only thing that'll get you a chance at
grabbing that ship
parker be waiting for you at lizzy's bar
thanks man
level up yeah
all right i'll be streaming tomorrow
guys hope to see you guys then
thanks for joining this one
that's fun i really like the game so
hard
very nice very very very nice all right
i got out of this stuff
i gotta i gotta do all right i got stuff
in my life
yeah breakfast thanks for joining guys
have a good one have a great one have a
fantastic one
bye bye
you